jamin we have a quote from you oh that
one of our people dug up gnomes came
from an article that jason heller from
well right yeah yeah and you say i think
the tendency in filmmaking is to always
do something bigger our trajectory is to
always do something better so how is the
frame better than ink man um that's a
good question you know I think with with
the frame in ink I you know I try to
with every film that we make I think the
tendency is to disparage the last film
that you made and be like all of this
sounds so much better I am
unquestionably more proud of this film
than I am of ink though I think it's a
more challenging film for audiences than
Ben I think ink is and I think I think
it's just a combination of a lot of
things I think we've just gotten to be
better filmmakers I think over the years
I've gotten to this I like to think I've
gotten to be a better writer and I think
that's probably one of the most
important things is just really knowing
how to write and that takes a long time
to this it's a tough skill to acquire
and just over the years i think i've
gotten better at it the the performances
in the frame are outstanding and I think
it's just for me for me personally it's
hitting on a deeper level than the new
didn't even eat was I think ink it
strikes a really personal chord as well
but for me the frame you know I guess
how do I put it it's just it's just
hitting things that I I spent a lot of
my life thinking about and and I guess
I'm just really proud to to have put
that on screen in a way that I think is
successful and and it's exactly what I
wanted to be and I think and I think at
the end of the day if you've just put on
screen what you intended it on screen
that you're succeeding you know and it's
so much less about how much of the
audience likes the film and more
you realizing your vision on screen and
to me that's what the frame is all of
those things and it's not a romantic
comedy from it sound really funny and
fun that's not great from what he yeah
so um I think we just you know it
getting through in because you guys know
talked with you about it before I was
really hard but and I'm I will always be
extremely proud of that movie and will
always love that movie but jamin I feel
really dug deep on a writing level and
and we just took no prisoners I feel
like we just dug deeper on every level
that we could production value ambition
and scope of the artistic scope of the
movie and yeah I'm I really love it I
love both but I'm with jam and I really
think we're both just really proud of
the film
you